justice and injustice in america two
cases gripping the nation the injustice
in wisconsin a new trial beginning over
the deaths of six innocent people at a
christmas parade over the weekend with
everyone wondering why the suspect was
allowed back out on the streets after
his last arrest then there is justice in
georgia a jury there just finding all
three men charged with ahmad arbrey's
death guilty of murder with the man who
pulled the trigger being found guilty on
all charges we take a look at both but
first jeff paul is at the courthouse in
georgia with more jeff
yeah dagging a huge sense of relief for
the hundreds of folks who were gathered
outside the courthouse here at one point
in brunswick georgia you could tell
there was a bit of nervousness as they
waited for the jury to come back from
deliberations with their decision but
once the judge started going down the
list of the defendants and all the
accounts they faced there was a lot of
celebration and cheering outside the
courthouse all three men found guilty of
multiple counts of murder it took the
jury just under 12 hours and two days to
come to that decision and for the family
and all the folks who've spent days on
end watching this trial they say justice
is
overarching word that comes to mind in
this situation they say the men
responsible for killing ahmad arbury are
finally being held accountable and that
his memory will now live on the way it
should
decades from now
they'll be talking about a boy named
ahmed aubry
that taught this country what justice
looks like
and let us know that all whites are not
racist come on and all the blacks are
not worthless come on and we're all your
children
now the lawyer for william roddy bryan
that's the man who filmed a portion of
the shooting
says he's going to be filing a motion
for a new trial in the coming weeks that
was expected the judge meanwhile saying
that sentencing could happen in a couple
of weeks but when you look at the
severity of all these counts they were
found guilty on it's likely that all
three men
could spend the rest of their life in
prison degen jeff thank you so much for
that greg very often the media and the
left insert race where there isn't where
it's not an issue but here it was yeah
i'm just glad that not all whites are
racist thank you thank you reverend
i wonder how tawanna brawley feels all
right so uh huma humans do like to group
things uh
especially when incidents happen close
together for me you have the rittenhouse
case and you have the arboree murders
these are close together but it shows
you that if you pick the right filter
which is the filter of self-defense you
would have easily predicted the outcomes
of both cases
if you had used a different filter like
race you wouldn't have but if you use
self-defense obviously written house
clearly self-defense armory obviously
clearly murder the prism the prism of
self-defense would have told you how how
that would have panned out but if you
just looked at it through race you would
have seen the rittenhouse case
incorrectly you would have been told uh
erroneously that his victims were black
and that it didn't matter if they were
white because those were white guys
protecting black protesters none of this
is real uh and you might have gotten the
arbory case correct but that would have
been probably by luck the point is you
need to have more than one filter in
life or you're going to be very very
confused i feel great about this
decision the justice system worked
especially when the media you know went
full-on as you said as you uh suggest
racist assuming that only
white jurors only vote in a specific way
and they grouped in a bigoted uniform
bigoted manner and we know that this
isn't true and it shows you how every
case is different every case is nuanced
avoid these sweeping generalizations
although my favorite take was from an
organization because right when a
verdict happens or the organizations
will send out an email to you about
this is my favorite one i won't say who
who this organization was the verdict is
a reminder of much needed reforms in our
nation's legal system so i was thinking
but what if it came back as not guilty
they would have had the same response so
hence their actual response is
inherently meaningless if you can use it
or apply it anywhere and dana the the
legal system worked in an incredible way
in the and it doesn't bring ahmad or
berry back but
the original prosecutor jackie johnson
on this case she
was removed the georgia
bureau of investigation took it over not
only did she lose re-election but she
was brought up on charges by a grand
jury related to her handling of it
because again
what happened was right remember because
she passed she was like yeah i'm not
going to prosecute
and then there was legitimate outrage
about that and eventually you get to
this result um one thing that's also
interesting is that we're celebrating
thanksgiving tomorrow as a country and
we give thanks for our nation and our
system and the a trial by jury it
sometimes it's slow and it takes a long
time it's been a year and a half but you
know what it works
and if if you are somebody who says well
it worked in uh one case and not in the
other in these two cases you can't
actually do that so i think that we have
kind of a lot to be grateful for and
that the system worked
in fact
to that point jessica aft after the
verdict you had a representative for the
prosecutor and ahmad barbara's family
and everyone standing around her
shearing the mention of law enforcement
cheering the mention of the prosecutors
and that's kind of
different refreshing and different
definitely well that's always been the
dichotomy versus what you hear about who
likes law enforcement and who actually
likes law enforcement like the highest
approval ratings for having more police
on the streets come out of the
communities that are most affected by
crime that's no surprise and
unfortunately in too many cities that's
black and brown communities that are
living below poverty lines etc i think
those moments are important hearing from
ahmad arbury's mother that her son is
finally at peace and at rest with
something particularly moving um
it was
pretty quick as well i know that
everyone thought this could come back
last night it seemed pretty conclusive
there were so many counts it was nine
counts i think
um for all of them to make sure that the
jury got through but this is a good day
and it's a good day like the day that
derek chovin was convicted as a good day
and also that kyle rittenhouse was let
off on a self-defense charge and i hope
that this starts a precedence of not
having these riots for these things
because that's really what you wake up
thinking like obviously you want someone
to go to jail if they have murdered
someone but you also fear
for your city your country wherever you
are that people are going to take to the
streets and it's going to turn into
the summer of 2020 again and hopefully
when things have gone through the legal
system and it does work the jury system
does work we can all just
sit there and take in what we heard
during the case and the verdict and be
calm about it right and if you have the
misfortune of living in a large liberal
city you have to sit back and watch
people set your city of fire and destroy
businesses and then never even get
charged with those with those crimes
you're from georgia how do you feel
about this
maybe not even feelings just what do you
think no listen
both of these cases had an element that
is kind of new to the world which is
video evidence and
i think one thing i took away from both
of these cases over the last two weeks
and what i hate is from the moment the
written house verdict was announced and
i started commenting on it as someone
who understands the second amendment and
firearms and the perspective i have to
to comment on the idea of self-defense
being completely legal to the moment
this verdict came out today there's like
a little section on twitter it's like
but what about the yamada aubry case
what about the armada aubry case i
didn't comment on kyle ridden house
until the jury had a chance to see every
shred of evidence and make a decision
then i could comment on things that i
thought understood but perhaps didn't
because i wasn't there every day of the
trial and the same thing with this
these men by all intents and purposes
and everything that was put out in the
public for me to digest
chased this man down and killed him
because they didn't like him in their
neighborhood and thought they could the
one thing that's scary about both of
these cases that i think really is what
we need to address is we have this
narrative oh we have this national uh
institution against poor people or
against black people no what we have are
we have small town courts and legal
systems that can screw you over in a
heartbeat i mean we had a prosecutor in
kenosha wisconsin that didn't want to
release the true video of kyle the the
aerial footage and then we had a
prosecutor in small town georgia that
might not have wanted to try this case
because either the optics of racism or
the fact that the neighbor was a retired
cop and neither one of those things
should ever happen in this country
that's the one thing we shouldn't have
to worry about is not having a chance at
a fair trial and at least with video
evidence that gets that much harder for
some small town legal system to to make
you the make you the victim of their own
angst or or inability to be embarrassed
by what happened in their town but but
you know it's next week right don't we
have just lane maxwell yes i mean
there's like these things and then i
think there's jesse smilette oh yeah
right in that one but are they i mean a
are they televised and b to your point
um just lane doesn't have there's no
video right right there's no video so
it's going to be one of those things
where we won't really understand it and
where you know we may not see what we
want to see well but there are a lot of
victims yes that are on record and are
already on tape so we will have
those interviews aired are they
televised are they those two televisions
we can check no we're a cable we should
television we should know this
oh actually it's not the voices in my
head just told me
[Laughter]
i know she wasn't you know now that
she's been in prison
uh she won't have the hairdo so i guess
that works out in her to her advantage
i'm just glad you know how to say her
name right i would not have i don't
think he's right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else